hello everyone
today's live broadcast scaling cell
therapy manufacturing presented by Jim
Beltzer PhD we are excited to bring you
this educational web seminar presented
by lab roots and sponsored by Tomo BCT
terumah BCT is a global leader in blood
component therapeutic a phoresis and
cellular technologies it is the only
company with a unique combination of a
phoresis collections manual and
automated whole blood processing and
pathogen reduction technologies Tarullo
BCT believes in the potential of blood
to do even more for patients than it
does today
this belief inspires the company's
innovation and strengthens its
collaboration with customers to learn
more about Jerome o BCT please visit
[Music]
www.opm.gov/life and for today's event
this webinar has been approved for
continuing educational credits please
click on the CD button at the bottom
left corner and follow the process to
receive your credits before we begin I
would like to remind everyone that this
event is interactive we encourage you to
participate by submitting as many
questions as you want and anytime you
want during the presentation just click
on the green Q&A button located in the
lower left of the presentation window
type your question into the box that
appears on the screen and we'll answer
as many questions as we have time for at
the end of the presentation also please
notice that you'll be viewing the
presentation in the slide window to
enlarge the window just click on the
screen icon located on the lower right
and finally if you have trouble seeing
or hearing the presentation please click
on the support button at the top right
of the presentation window or use the
Q&A button to let us know you're having
a problem thank you now I'd like to
introduce dr. belt sir prior to joining
the cell processing team at Jerome o BCT
dr. belt who served as lead scientist
for the Rd of Corning synthamax a
synthetic growth surface for the culture
of human embryonic stem cells at corning
life sciences he was a co-founder of red
corporation and was a key player in the
industrialization of several technology
platforms including phage display and
yeast two-hybrid
he has more than 20 years of industrial
research and development
in a broad range of disciplines please
join me in welcoming dr. belt sir I will
now turn the presentation over to him
today I'd like to present three case
studies in cell therapy manufacturing t
cell expansion case study viral vector
production case study and finally
producing a 10 quantum system watch
before I get to that I would like to
introduce you to the quantum cell
expansion system the quantum is a novel
hollow fiber bioreactor system that is
closed uses continuous perfusion and as
a single use system it's primarily
designed for adherence cells but we also
have some results growing Suspension
cells in the quantum we have automated
all of the necessary steps for
traditional cell culture and we have
extremely good control over the gas
exchange and the temperature in the
quantum this is the single use part this
is the quantum disposable and you can
see the bioreactor on the right and then
the tubing organizer is how the plumbing
interacts with the pumps and valves on
the quantum system and then to the left
of the screen you can see a couple of
the bags that are attached to the
harvest bag and the waste bag so here we
have the quantum system with that
disposable mounted so you can see the
hollow fiber bioreactor in the middle of
your screen you can see the four pumps
to control the fluid input to the system
and the circulation of the fluid in the
system also on the Left we have the gas
Inlet and the gas transfer module which
is responsible for all of the gas
exchange that takes place in the quantum
system so where the rubber hits the road
is the hollow fiber bioreactor it's
composed of about 11,500 semipermeable
hollow fibers and you can think of those
as very small straws the equivalent
surface area is about a hundred and
twenty P 175 flaps and the cells grow on
the inside of those hollow fibers as
shown in the micrograph that's on the
top right of the screen so there are
basically two different fluid paths
within the hollow fiber bioreactor the
icy loop which runs down the center of
those straws of the hollow fiber and
basically passes straight from left to
right through the center of the
bioreactor and then there's the extra
capillary loop and you can see the inlet
and outlet of that sticking up on the
top of the bioreactor and that's
basically the bath water that fills the
space that surrounds these hollow fibers
and so there we can achieve perfusion
feeding of the selves we can use both of
these loops to our advantage so I show
here a hydraulic layout system for the
quantum with the icy loop and the EC
loop shown in red and blue and the
hollow fiber bioreactor shown in the
middle so these controls of inlet and
circulation pumps will become very
important so with the door closed the
bioreactor is now an incubator in fact
we call it a cleanroom in a box all of
the controls are accomplished through
the automated touch screen on the front
of the machine you can see running
across the top the inlets and outlets
are described and that's one thing the
quantum is not smart enough to know
which bag you've attached to which inlet
line so you have to call that out you
also have control of the various inlet
pumps on the yellow or for the icy side
and in the blue or for the EC side and
you can see the bioreactor
in the middle of your screen
now our engineers have gone to a lot of
trouble to describe a number of
predefined tasks and multi-step tasks so
they're either single step or multi step
these describe to the best of our
ability all the necessary tasks that you
need to perform to culture cells in the
bioreactor but the most important part
of this entire slide is the purple
button that fits above each task
description and that's the modify button
so all of these tasks are modifiable to
meet your cell culture needs in fact you
can create custom tasks and link them
together to describe even as much as
your entire run in a single custom step
we track the growth of our cells by
sampling media most commonly from the EC
port there's a lure lock port that's
shown on the left but if you need to get
a sample of the contents of the IC coil
right so that's the IC loop that the
cells are growing on in that loop you
can weld off a portion of the sample
coil as shown on the right before I go
into the case studies I'd like to
introduce a car T cell therapy
manufacturing that's in development at
room o so the basic process is an a
phoresis product is can be purified into
lymphocytes and then those lymphocytes
are either gene modified and then
activated and expanded finally the
expanded cells are concentrated and
washed and eventually infused into the
patients this can be accomplished using
true mobile devices so the Spector Optio
can give you a phoresis product and
lymphocytes can be purified using the
Eleuthera cell separation system so I'd
like to concentrate on two aspects of
this process that utilize the quantum
system
the first is activation and expansion of
t-cells in the in the quantum system and
the second is the production of viral
vectors using the quantum system as well
so let's start with t-cell expansion in
the quantum system so this is our basic
cell expansion of t-cells in the quantum
system and we typically start out with
2.5 mils of a Luka phoresis product or
25 mils of a looot reiated product and
you can get those either from the
apheresis or from the lucra machine we
loaded 100 million lymphocyte into the
Machine approximately two hundred and
twenty eight million excuse me of those
cells were cd3 plus t cells those cells
were activated with cd3 cd28 dynabeads
in a two-to-one ratio of selves to b and
then fed by continuous perfusion so
that's on d0 on day 3 6 & 9 we introduce
a bolus of il-2 and aisle 7 as you can
see on the timeline and there's a
minimal amount of circulation in the IC
loop where the cells are of 1 mil per
minute so that's really quite slow and
our gas exchange is taken care of by the
circulating the EC loop at a hundred
mils per minute that's also clearing out
any waste products that may have been
produced by the expansion of themselves
after day six we do flip the bioreactor
once a day just to break apart the
clumps finally on day 12 we harvest the
cells and we were able to harvest after
a 12 day expansion about 15 billion
t-cells greater than 500 full
expansion in 12 days and an aloe harvest
volume of 0.5 to 1 liter now I've shown
this same data in a different format
here so you can see on day 0 we started
out with 28 million CD 3 plus T cells
and then in the blue bar in the last
column we end up with 15 billion CD 3
plus T cells also of interest is that we
get a selective enrichment of the cd8
cells that shows up quite nicely in day
9 and day 12 if we look at the flow
results you can see that we end up with
a 99% pure T cell population and that's
also a preferential expansion of our cd8
cells as I mentioned before coming up to
about 69% in the final product there is
a significant drop in the PD 1
expression and our T cells are
expressing il-2 and interferon gamma the
activation markers so just in summary
then we had over a five hundred fold
expansion of CD plus CD 3 plus T cells
over 12 days
no pre-processing a closed system
automated reduces labor it can be used
in a controlled space perfusion fed and
we use a low amount of media in the
process then we have a low volume for
our harvest moving on to viral vector
production in the quantum system so many
of you are familiar with growing
incubators full of flasks or sell stocks
or roller bottles in order to collect
your viral vector supernatant and I've
heard stories of up to 16 10 stacks
going into a single prep so this is a
our intensive process many open steps
there's a clean room is required because
you've got high concentration of virus
large volumes of vector and it's very
contamination prone there are two types
of virus expression they're stable and
transient expression of viral vectors
stable trans section of retro viral
vectors is usually done using a
packaging cell line and your gene of
interest is introduced into a packaging
cell for those purposes transient
expression on the other hand involves
introducing all of the genes required to
produce the virus including the envelope
the gag and the paul-jean so you would
introduce a mixture of four plasmids
into the transient transfection mix both
the packaging cell line in the transient
expression systems has their pros and
cons so the packaging cell line is
obviously very convenient and allows for
stable expression for weeks but that
initial construction of the cell line
can be difficult transient expression on
the other hand is stable for 40 to 72
hours and it is fast and achieves
comparable titers the cons is that's the
batch variability and difficult to scale
both of these protocols have been used
on the quantum system here's a cartoon
of our transient expression experiments
to produce lentiviral vectors in the
quantum and this was done in
collaboration with Gerhart Bauer's lab
at UC Davis or gen medicine Center so
the first is to load your HK 293 t-cells
if you're in a hurry and you want to
start the next day then you would load
up at least a billion cells into the
bioreactor
if you wish to let the cells expand
first in the bioreactor you can load
fewer cells and allow them to expand so
cells are loaded and allowed to attach
to the bioreactor for 15 hours or
overnight and then when the population
of cells has filled the bioreactor to
approximately 1 to 1.5 billion cells
then you can begin your transfection
and so that's day 1 of the process so
the transfection you add the 4 plasmid
as I spoke just spoke about for the
transient expression of lentivirus in
calcium phosphate and you allow the
transaction to proceed for 15 hours in
the quantum and then at the end of that
15 hours you wash out and do an
induction for another 9 hours so at the
end of that time we want to collect the
virus this is on day 4 and we wanted to
be able to concentrate the virus
afterwards so there was a switch to
serum free media and we then proceeded
to feed the cells for 40 hours during
that time we continuously collected the
viral vector in the supernatant or the
conditioned media that passed over the
cells on day 5 we harvested the cells we
got back our 1 to 2.5 billion to 93 T
cells we were able to titer and
concentrate the virus particles and
determine the mo I and the T use per mil
so we've shown that the quantum system
can be used to produce retroviral and
lentiviral vectors it's automated it's
capable of achieving both stable and
transient extraction systems it's a
closed system the vector concentration
is equal to what we see in Flast based
system and using engineering controls we
can control the volume of the vector
containing supernatant and in the next
slide I show the hydraulic system
again to show you how important that is
in concentrating and decreasing the
volume of our virus containing
supernatant so basically that's achieved
by harvesting the IC loop so you can see
in the diagram that we harvest the IC
loop into a separate bag from the EC
loop where we accomplish the feeding of
the cells and so in summary the results
of our viral vector production in the
quantum for the lentivirus we got about
2 times 10 to the 8th viral particles
per mil which was a similar yield to
what's normally obtained in the cell
stack likewise again a retrovirus gave
similar results at youth as to what they
had been getting in their plastic base
system and there will be references for
both of these results at the end of the
talk and moving on to the allogeneic
model which is a case study in scaling
out the quantum system from one machine
to ten machines so this case study was a
collaboration between a thesis and its
European subsidiary Regenesis and the
contract manufacturing organization of
master cell so the object was to
transfer the process of so growing map
sees in the quantum to scale that
process out from one machine to ten
machines to create a larger lot size and
then finally to see if there are any
efficiencies that could be gained and
cutting straight to the chase we found
that there was a forty percent cost a
forty percent reduction in the cost of
goods producing cells in this way so in
the first slide we show the technology
transfer
timeline through to scale out so the
first few weeks were spent simply
learning how to run the quantum and then
another six weeks were used for process
optimization most of this work was on
downstream processing of the cell
product and finally the ten quantum runs
were
in the scale ouch so this is a
comparison of running a single quantum
system here in the box on the bottom it
tells you how many people are required
so you can see on day one we take two
operators to run the quantum system
that's mostly to prepare the cells and
the quantum for loading with the ten
quantum system you see at the box at the
top that two operators are also required
in day zero and day one or day minus one
and day zero but basically the
intermediate steps can be handled by a
single operator and as I said before the
harvest day is the most difficult and
here we needed more help so finally if
you look at the product that we got you
can see that the flow cytometry profiles
from the comparing the quantum produced
cells to the self stack produce cells
are equal and same the same is true for
the protein secretion so you can see
that we were able to develop a process
that can yield consistent cell qualify
quality and yield and can simplify the
progression from learning to production
and importantly there's a 40% cost
reduction in cost of goods and we were
able to produce large lots of cells so
here are the references for the lenta
borrow the retroviral and finally the
scale out of the quantum cell expansion
system thank you very much
Thank You dr. Zeltzer for that
informative presentation it is time for
Q&A if you have a question you'd like to
ask dr. Bell sir please do so now just
click on the green Q&A button at the
lower left of the presentation window
type your question into the box that
appears on your screen
and click on the send button well answer
as many of your questions as we have
time for let's get started our first
question is can you control the shear
stress in the quantum for the growth of
endothelial cells thanks for that
question first of all there's very
little shear stress in the quantum
system that's pure physics that you've
got a quarter inch Inlet line going into
the icy loop and a two inch in diameter
bioreactor there's very little shear
that happens having said that though we
can control the flow rate of the media
through the icy loop with our pumps and
if needed we can even feed across the
membrane without creating a shear stress
how can I monitor the growth of the
cells in the bottom so you can monitor
the growth in the in the quantum by
taking a sample from the EEC sample port
so that's a lure lock port that is
sterile so there's a point two micron
filter behind it we recommend that you
monitor the lactate production and
glucose consumption and typically those
measurements are done once every 24
hours has the quat have been used to
culture IPS cells yes the quantum has
been used to successfully expand IPS
cells we haven't done differentiation of
IPS cells yet in the quantum but that's
ongoing in fact recent experiments have
shown that the quantum can significantly
reduce the media required to expand IPS
cells what is the media perfusion rate
in the quantum well the media perfusion
rate typically starts out at 0 or very
low so to what point 1 mil per minute in
the beginning stages of a tip
expansion and it may go as high as one
point six mils per minute at the end of
a typical MSC expansion for viral
vectors and and other applications we
may have to go higher as the cell
densities increase within the quantum so
for the viral vector case we are running
up around 2.5 minutes is there a reason
for switching to serum free media for
viral vector production ah yes so that's
a good question if you produce your
viral vectors in serum containing media
it complicates the concentration of that
virus product after you have finished
your run so the serum proteins would
quickly clog the membrane concentrators
that are typically used to concentrate
viral vectors how are the dynabeads
loaded into the system for T cell
expansions very simple we basically mix
the dynabeads with the cells in a cell
inlet bag prior prior to loading the
self into the bioreactor and as I
mentioned ya the ratio is 2 to 1 today
we've tried both tex max and RPM i + 2 %
human a B serum and right now we get the
best results with our PMI but we plan to
test more media in the future so stay
tuned we're almost out of time so this
will have to be our last question how
our suspension cells kept in the hollow
fiber bioreactor so our pumps the
circulation pumps in the quantum accel x
10 system can be reversed so we can run
those pumps in such a fashion as to push
the any cells that may have gotten out
into the rest of the ICU loop back into
the bioreactor so again we just use our
circulation pumps I would like to once
again thank dr. Belcher for his
presentation
have any final comments I just want to
thank everybody and if you have any
questions further to this please contact
me at my email that should be on the
last slide of the presentation well
thank you once again I would also like
to thank our sponsor two-room OB CT for
making today's educational webcast
possible this webinar has been approved
for continuing educational credits
please click on the CD button at the
bottom left corner and follow the
process to receive your credits and
before we go I want to let everyone know
that today's webcast will be available
for on-demand viewing through November
31st 2017 you'll receive an email from
lab roots letting you know when this
webcast will be available for replay
please share that announcement with your
colleagues who may have missed today's
live event that's all for now thank you
for joining us and we hope to see you
again soon goodbye
you